Liyana Galera coming to you live from
New York comic-con right now with my
personal favorite cast the cast and two
producers of Outlander so first off two
quick things happy belated birthday
Capri very much thank you how was your
day yesterday how'd you celebrate I flew
to New York and I dinner with some of my
favorite people and we are all please
tell me you had plenty of whiskey last
night I had no whiskey but plenty of
other stuff we celebrated and there was
cake as well there's no stranger to New
York comic-con what's it like to be able
to be here to get to connect with the
fans it's amazing I mean I think that we
shoot for so long in Scotland and we
really are in such a little bubble and
when we get a chance like this to come
out and meet the fans
and they're so supportive and generous
and suites and it just yeah it makes it
we sometimes forget about you know sort
of the enthusiasm and the anticipation
for the next season and it's like
energizing as well there is to see
people dressed up you know as you are as
your character or have you seen any more
haven't seen any motors and I'm quite
angry about it you should write a letter
no but it's a giant gray cat so much
into talking about
[Music]
so many fun things to look forward to in
season five a lot of drama and true
Outlander fashion but what I'm curious
to know about is are we gonna be just
pulling from Diana Gabaldon to fiery
cross or are we going to be outsourcing
to any more of her books this season I
like the hand action Elaine are we I
think we're able to say we're bringing
in certain elements of the next book
and I think you know we yeah I'm not
sure how much I'd say that some elements
yes I think it's all within and that our
world but there's also there's also
another story obviously you know Martha
was not in the in the books and that
yeah well in this part of the book sent
yeah I think that's a really interesting
storyline we have yeah well let's pick
up of course on our season four
cliffhanger
Jamie gets that notice from the governor
saying that he needs to form a militia
against the regulator's specifically
against this guy right here what can we
expect and and I also want to know a
little bit more about this romance we
got brewing questions so what can you
tease about what's coming up for the two
of you guys in this fifth season oh gosh
well I definitely have relationships in
season five
but we can talk a little bit about the
fact that we were picking up on some
romance vibes between and Jocasta and
Murtagh it looks like Jamie was feeling
it at the end and trying to figure out
what was going on what do you think it
is about the two of them that makes such
a good pair it's mo caster the mercaptan
lovin is real I think it's like this
incredible thing when they meet they've
known each other like their whole values
maybe and for Jocasta somebody to come
back again and who has a whole wealth of
the same shared experience the same
landscape and language and so much that
they understand together without having
to talk and I think she probably always
had a little I for him but it was clear
that he was in love with her sister so
she didn't she loved her sister she
didn't go Messing
kind of like a black widow like she's
got a lot of my she's yeah they're our
money yeah I mean there's something a
little fishy about those love engagement
rings but I feel like we just reunited
with Murtagh I'm not ready to say
goodbye to him please tell me that we
can hold out hope are we thinking about
we we love we love the character and
certainly it's a really really strong
story for Marty he's pitched against
Jamie and their own sort of opposing
sides of this is war and I think that's
a really strong soil actually worked
yeah I mean I think the most interesting
things I have to pay gonna you gonna say
it's these good vibes some grainy Jesus
well David it was so nice to see Lord
John Gray come back into the fold in
season four and bring of course little
William with him what can you tease for
the fans about season five and we get to
see more of that extended Frasier family
dynamic
but yes Lord John does appear in season
five I guess can I taste it's quite
clear that Lord John sides
this whole regulated thing that's going
on and I think Lord John sort of in the
middle playing both sides does his
allegiances are to the phrases and to
the crown so I guess that kind of plays
for some interesting drama you'll see
what that goes
like I said at the start of the
interview congratulations are due for
Sam and Katrina because you all have
been promoted to producers in addition
to our leads we're looking to fire
someone like so do you guys get any
extra perks that come with that what
does that like to be able to also have a
little bit of a pull do the job maybe
kind of influence what you'd like to see
for your characters in the season no
it's been really interesting I think for
both of us to be able to sort of take
all this different responsibilities I
mean obviously we sort of got this role
after the book had already been broken
and the story lines had already been
drawn but we've definitely been brought
in earlier in the scripts and it's
really interesting to see sort of behind
the scenes the work that goes into it
and and I think you know having that
understanding of why certain things are
the way they are and everything has been
quite a cool learning experience it's
just I mean we've always known our crew
are fantastic but you know we're now
we're sort of both in productions and
things we see the sort of preparation
that goes into into work and there's
just this vast army of people behind the
scenes that are working in each year a
day-in day-out so to make a show and
it's it's we're very lucky
now in the fiery cross there are two
weddings that take place so I'm curious
to know are there wedding bells ringing
maybe at Riverrun or Fraser's Ridge
she's definitely a wedding there's yes
the Stanley a Wed a wedding we just
don't know whose wedding maybe we renew
our vows oh don't suggest that that
would be lovely
what can you tease about Jamie and
Clare's dynamic as we go into season
five we really got to see some sweet
at-home moments with them are we gonna
get to see more of that Fraser family
bonding what can you tell us I think you
know I think this is a really strong
season for everyone but I think for
Claire and Jamie it's this beautiful
deepening of a relationship and that's
what's so great about getting to be on a
show for this long is that you get to
really live with these characters you
know with the I'm getting older there's
a lot of wisdom they know each other so
much and you know it just
they love deepens and I think people
sort of fall in love sometimes with the
early passion over you know sort of the
more day-to-day kind of connection and I
think that that's actually much more
exciting
yeah and you know there restrung
together there's still a lot of humor
there's still a lot of passion but it's
also you notice all season that I think
is about the family and about the family
sort of needing each other to to fight
the sort of exterior forces and the
family really is getting torn apart Isis
how are they like as Grandparents pretty
you know Roger is pretty tough when
Roger Chetty Oh grumpy brandeis yeah
meet the phrases Sophie and Richard are
of course filming right now and that's
why they can't join us but did you
actually think that I wouldn't tec sofie
and have her give you guys a surprise oh
so we have a special question coming in
right now from sophie Skelton and she
says hmm if you all could make a
cocktail called the Felicia would be in
it now before you answer please give us
some context because she would not fill
me in on this one nothing is off-limits
I think it's everything goes in there
okay start throwing out ingredients
there would be well we'd have to go with
the base but let's go Robin because
we're in America tomato juice in tequila
in a porridge Sam what we're talking
about drinks let's do a natural segue so
that you can plug your new whiskey that
you're working on right now what can you
tell for the fans out there about the
sasirekha whiskey yes you'll be hitting
America hopefully
time for Christmas I will be doing
pre-orders and limited edition and it's
just been a real passion project of mine
and I've really enjoyed reading so being
part of this whole process is my soul I
still site have you shared a dream with
any of your outlet a fan know it's
coming but even though Sophie and
Richard are not here of course we want
to talk about Roger and Bri what can you
tease about their dynamic moving forward
and will we get to see that first
interaction between Roger and baby who
has not to be named but although in the
Book of Jeremiah
[Laughter]
like one can ideas it through a lot
actually I was up there was a very
loaded question yes I think this is a
really great season for Brianna and
Rogers characters they go through a lot
you know they have a lot to overcome in
their relationship I mean the events of
the end of last season it's not
something that you can just fix in one
fell swoop so you know they have to
really learn how to I guess cope with
what happened and the consequences of
that but they're also being parents for
the first time and everything that that
entails so it's it's a really great
storyline and and also just getting used
to living with that the you know normal
comforts of the modern one of my
favorite sweet moments of season four
was when Claire and Bri were just naming
things that they missed from the modern
age cheeseburgers and all that great
stuff are we going to be getting a lot
more mother-daughter bonding oh we have
some great stuff and I always love
working with Sophie me she's so
incredible she's such a talented actress
and
you know whenever we do get to have
those moments that's always really
special we can we definitely have a few
great ones a season two I loved getting
to explore Brees dynamic with each of
you in season four but I particularly
loved her dynamic Lafleur John Gray what
was it like for you guys to find that
connection of faux engagement for a
little bit I was I guess I had to kind
of defer my I guess my romance from from
Jamie to just three kind of by proxy for
a second but it was a very you know
whirlwind romance because it didn't last
very long
we get off stage by a Roger of course
that's okay I got Jamie in my life
somehow and I'll find my way back to you
gently I'm still here still here saddest
tale of unrequited love really honest
I'm shedding it's here right could there
ever be a chance that he could find
someone new to love single and ready you
know she's single and ready to see my
wingwoman do you know anyone she's my
head building tonight thank you all so
much for joining me I really appreciate
it and for all you fans out there stick
with the stream and for more Outlander
season five premieres on February 16th
2020 on Starz we'll see you soon bye
guys
[Music]